9:00 A.M. EASTERN TIME, TUCKER
IS COMING UP NEXT.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE’RE MONITORING THE PRESIDENT’S
REMARKS.
WE GO THERE IF BREAKING NEWS
OCCURS.
WHAT CAN YOU BUY WITH $460
MILLION?
YOU CAN BUY A LOT OF THINGS.
A BOEING 747 IF YOU WANTED ONE,
AN ENTIRE NFL STADIUM.
YOU CAN GET A PACK OF PEANUT M&M
M&Ms FOR EVERY PERSON IN THE
COUNTRY OR GET THAT MONEY AND
GET HUMILIATED BY ELIZABETH
WARREN IN FRONT OF THE COUNTRY.
THAT’S WHAT HAPPENED.
BLOOMBERG WOULDN’T BE THE FIRST
RICH LIBERAL WITH UNUSUAL
TASTES.
WARREN WAS HAPPY TO PLAY ALONG.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE EXCHANGES
WORTH REPLAYING AGAIN AND AGAIN
AND AGAIN.
ELIZABETH WARREN SPANKED HIM
LIKE THE BAD BILLIONAIRE HE IS
VIGOROUSLY.
WATCH.
>> I’D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
WE’RE RUNNING AGAINST.
A BILLIONAIRE THAT CALLS WOMEN
FAT BROADS AND HORSE-FACED
LESBIANS.
NO, I’M NOT TALKING ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP.
I’M TALKING ABOUT MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG.
DEMOCRATS WON’T WIN IF WE HAVE A
NOMINEE WITH A HISTORY OF HIDING
TAX RETURNS, HARASSING WOMEN AND
SUPPORTING RACIST POLICIES.
DEMOCRATS TAKE A HUGE RISK IF WE
JUST SUBSTITUTE ONE ARROGANT
BILLIONAIRE FOR ANOTHER.
>> Tucker: YOU WONDER HOW OFTEN
BLOOMBERG PAYS TO GET YELLED AT
LIKE THAT.
AT ONE POINT, ELIZABETH WARREN
FORCED BLOOMBERG TO ADMIT THAT
HE WOULDN’T ALLOW STRANGE FEMALE
EMPLOYEES ABOUT WORKING FOR HIM.
>> HE’S GOTTEN SOME NUMBER OF
WOMEN TO SIGN NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS FOR DISCRIMINATION IN
THE WORKPLACE.
MR. MAYOR, ARE YOU ABLE TO
RELEASE THOSE WOMEN FROM THOSE
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS SO WE
CAN HEAR THEIR SIDE OF THE
STORY?
IF THEY WISH TO SPEAK OUT AND
TELL THEIR SIDE OF THE STORY
ABOUT WHAT IT IS THEY ALLEGE,
THAT IS NOW OKAY WITH YOU?
YOU’RE RELEASING THEM ON
TELEVISION TONIGHT?
>> SENATOR, NO.
>> Tucker: HOLY SMOKES!
MAKES YOU WONDER ABOUT ELIZABETH
WARREN
WARREN’S HUSBAND BACK HOME.
REMEMBER, SHE ASKED FOR HIS HAND
IN MARRIAGE.
HE SAID YES.
AN OFFER HE COULDN’T REFUSE.
IN THE FACE OF A WOMAN LIKE
THAT, MIKE BLOOMBERG CRUMBLES.
HE DIDN’T LOOK RICH.
HE LOOK OLD AND WEAK.
HE COULDN’T EXPLAIN HIS OWN
CANADADIDACY
CANDIDACY, MADE APOLOGIES FOR
HIS RECORD.
HE BRAGGED ABOUT CUTTING NEW
YORK CITY’S CRIME RATE IN HALF
AND DISAVOWED THE POLICY THAT
MADE IT POSSIBLE.
>> IF I GO BACK AND LOOK AT MY
TIME IN OFFICE, THE ONE THING
I’M REALLY WORRIED ABOUT,
EMBARRASSED ABOUT IS HOW IT
TURNED OUT WITH STOP AND FRISK.
>> Tucker: HOW BAD WAS IT?
EVEN ON THE MOST OBVIOUS
QUESTION, THE ONE HE HAD THE
KNOW WAS COMING, HOW CAN SOMEONE
AS RICH AS YOU RELATE TO NORMAL
VOTERS?
BLOOMBERG WHIFFED IT.
APPARENTLY THE ARMY OF
CONSULTANTS HE HIRED TO WRITE
HIS LINES FORGOT ABOUT IT.
MAYBE HE GOT SICK OF BEING SELF-
SELF-DEFINITESELF-
SELF-DEFINITE  --
SELF-DEPRICATING.
YOU KNOW DON’T USE TURBO TAX
WHEN YOU’RE AS RICH AS HE IS.
>> FORTUNATELY I MAKE A LOT OF
MONEY AND WE DO BUSINESS AROUND
THE WORLD AND THE NUMBER OF
PAGES WILL BE IN THOUSANDS OF
PAGES.
I CAN’T GO TO TURBO TAX.
>> Tucker: OH, BUT DIDN’T GET
BETTER FROM THERE.
THE CONVERSATION TURNED TO
CHINA.
BLOOMBERG KNOW AS LOT ABOUT
HE’S GETTING RICH THERE IN
DEFENDING ITS FASCIST GOVERNMENT
FOR MANY YEARS.
LAST NIGHT, NOT SURPRISINGLY, HE
WAS STILL ACTING LIKE CHINA’S
PUBLICIST.
WHEN ASKED ABOUT THEIR CARBON
EMISSIONS, BLOOMBERG SAID THAT
END I CAN’T WAS A BIGGER
PROBLEM, WHICH IS A TOTAL CROCK.
YOU HAVE GOOGLE.
CHECK IT YOURSELF.
CHINA EMITS 29% OF THE WORLD’S
CARBON.
TWICE AS MUCH AS THE U.S. AND
THE NUMBER IS RISING, NOT
FALLING.
INDIA, THE BIGGER PROBLEM,
ACCOUNTS FOR 7% OF THE WORLD’S
CARBON EMISSIONS.
YEAH.
BLOOMBERG’S CHINESE MASTERS ARE
NOT PLEASED BY THE LIE.
BY THE END OF THE NIGHT, HE
FAILED SO COMPLETELY, SO
UTTERLY, THAT HIS ODDS OF
WINNING THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINATION DROPPED BY A THIRD ON
THE BETTING SITE PREDICTED.
EVEN THE ANALYSTS ON CABLE NEWS,
MANY OF WHOM SECRETLY HOPED TO
WORK FOR MICHAEL BLOOMBERG HAD
TO ADMIT HIS PERFORMANCE WAS
HISTORIC AWFUL.
REALLY A NEW LOW IN THE HISTORY
OF SPOKEN ENGLISH.
>> GLORIA, WHAT IS THE BIG
HEADLINE?
>> BLOOMBERG WAS AWFUL.
>> THIS WAS A DISASTER FOR
BLOOMBERG.
>> THEY TORE THE SKIN OFF OF HIM
LAST NIGHT IN LAS VEGAS.
>> HE’S PROBABLY DOUBLING THE
SALARIES OF HIS STAFF.
I WOULDN’T WANT TO DEFEND HIM
AFTER THE NIGHT HE HAD.
>> IT WAS A DEVASTATING
INTRODUCTION FOR MIKE BLOOMBERG
TO A LOT OF AMERICA.
>> HE WENT IN AS THE TITANIC
MACHINE.
TITANIC, MEET ELIZABETH WARREN.
>> SHE LEFT BLOOMBERG IN A
PUDDLE ON THAT DEBATE STAGE.
>> Tucker: ALL TRUE FOR ONCE.
BLOOMBERG ATE IT LAST NIGHT.
HERE’S THE QUESTION.
DOES IT ACTUALLY MATTER?
THAT’S WHAT IS WORTH THINKING
ABOUT.
THE ANSWER IS IT DOESN’T REALLY
MATTER.
BLOOMBERG HURT HIM, BUT SHE
DIDN’T HURT HERSELF MUCH.
NOT A SINGLE PERSON WATCHING
WANTS TO LISTEN TO HER FOR THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS.
BLOOMBERG IS STILL RICH AND
STILL BLANKETING DAYTIME
TELEVISION WITH HIS ADS.
FAR MORE AMERICANS WILL SEE
BLOOMBERG’S COMMERCIALS THAN
WATCHED THIS DEBATE.
THAT’S THE TRUTH OF IT.
SO FOR THE HIGHLY ENTERTAINING
MOMENTS, THE DEBATE DIDN’T
CHANGE THE RACE.
BERNIE SANDERS IS STILL THE
FRONTRUNNER AND IF ANYTHING,
HE’S BECOMING LESS IMPRESSIVE AS
HE RISES IN THE POLLS.
LAST NIGHT HE LAMELY TRIED TO
CLAIM THAT HIS ONLINE
SUPPORTERS, THE ONE HARASSING
OPPONENTS ON TWITTER MIGHT BE
SECRET RUSSIAN AGENTS TRYING TO
SOW DISCORD IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
SANDERS SAID THAT ON STAGE.
UNFORTUNATELY PEOPLE WERE TO
DUMB TO NOTICE IT.
SO NOBODY ASKED A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION.
MEANWHILE, THE VARIOUS
DEMOCRATIC ALSO-RANS SPENT THEIR
EVENING SAVAGING EACH OTHER.
DID THEY.
AMY KLOBUCHAR, SUPPOSED TO BE
NICE, TOOK A BALL PEEN HAMMER TO
PETE BUTTIGIEG.
WATCH THIS.
>> YOU’RE STAKING YOUR CANDIDACY
ON YOUR WASHINGTON EXPERIENCE.
YOU’RE ON THE COMMITTEE THAT
OVERSEES BORDER SECURITY, YOU’RE
ON THE COMMITTEE THAT DOES
TRADE.
YOU’RE PART OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT IS OVERSEEING THESE THINGS
AND WE’RE NOT ABLE TO SPEAK TO
THE FIRST THING ABOUT THE
POLITICS OF THE CRISIS ITSELF.
>> ARE YOU TRYING TO SAY I’M
DUMB OR ARE YOU MOCKING ME HERE,
PETE?
I WISH EVERYONE WAS AS PERFECT
AS YOU, PETE.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT IT’S LIKE
TO BE IN THE ARENA.
I’M SO PROUD OF THE WORK I’VE
DONE ON IMMIGRATION REFORM.
YOU HAVE NOT BEEN IN THE ARENA
DOING THAT WORK.
YOU’VE MEMORIZED A BUNCH OF
TALKING POINTS.
>> Tucker: WOW!
SO THAT WAS REAL.
SHE CLEARLY HATES HIM.
GOOD FOR HER, BY THE WAY.
HE’S AWFUL.
HE’S THE FAKEST GUY IN THE RACE.
NOT THAT IT MATTERS.
NEITHER ONE IS GOING ANYWHERE IN
THE END.
THINGS GOT SO FRACKTIOUS, THEY
COULDN’T GET BEHIND THE
CANDIDATE THAT GOT THE MOST
VOTES.
THEY CALLED THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE RACIST AND ALL THAT
MATTERS IS THE POPULAR VOTE.
OF COURSE, THEY NEVER MEANT
THAT.
THE ONLY PERSON THAT MEANS IT IS
THE BERNIE SANDERS.
THE ONLY REASON HE MEANS IT, IN
THIS CASE HE’S THE ONLY ONE THAT
CAN BENEFIT FROM THAT STANDARD.
IT’S HARD TO SEE HOW ANYBODY GET
THE MAJORITY OF PRIMARY VOTES
BUT SANDERS IS STILL LIKELY TO
HAVE THE MOST IN THE END.
IN A TYPICAL YEAR THAT WOULD
MAKE HIM THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
NIECE NOT THE CASE THIS YEAR.
SO WHO WINS?
WHO IS THE NOMINEE?
THAT IS SOMETHING OUR FRIENDS IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WILL HAVE